I know that you have challenges as far
as your family is concerned and tell me
what the latest situation is
we had some great news uh early hours of
uh the morning that they had been found
we're very very happy for that we're
very relieved it comes a little bit of
sweet to tell the truth because of
the amount of people that are still
there family friends cypriots Turkish
people and everyone from around the
world that are stuck there
they've been found we're happy
um yeah
do you know what happened to them
um they've been rescued quite recently
haven't they but quite recently they
were rescued yeah we haven't had too
much information on them but we know
they've been pulled from the rubble and
they uh they're safe at the moment which
we're very thankful for so thank you for
all your well wishes and prayers
I mean you must be so relieved
we are we are we are so relieved we are
so so relieved we still have uh family
friends people that we know still out
there uh under the rubble um
looking for still missing as well which
is uh like I said it's a little bit
Bittersweet but we're very very relieved
thank you
yeah eight
coming now thick and fast it's taken a
while hasn't it
it has taken a while we started as soon
as it happened I I got a plan and we
came to the side but as you can see
behind me there's lorries uh loading
there's their poles all over Cypress
cyber people come together and unite as
one and we're constantly sending planes
and uh lorries out to Turkey
as we speak but it seems to be getting
worse it seems to be getting worse
people are needing that warm uh tents
they're needing electric blankets uh the
aid has to still keep coming in
um I know how difficult it is there my
biggest fear like I said first time when
I spoke to Sky is that people might
start turning on each other I know that
the government's doing a lot more now to
help they're sending people in uh
friends of mine at Special Forces
friends of mine are out there a friend
of mine said yesterday he pulled six out
live uh from the rubble yesterday at the
region which we're very grateful for so
everybody's help is appreciated and
loved here
yeah well that's good and I'm thrilled
to hear your good news this morning
thank you for joining us thanks a lot
thank you so much and we'll be there
soon